well I'm now joined by Former
Intelligence and security officer Philip
Ingram and Philip good to have you here
with us just to go through things and
unpick um what's going on just bring us
up to date with the latest situation
then with the tanks because we know that
the UK is supplying 14 of its Challenger
2 tanks yes day 332 of Vladimir Putin's
10-day special military operation and as
Deborah Haynes said the discussions at
Ramstein this meeting of 50 countries
discussing uh equipment going to Ukraine
at all centered around the The Leopard 2
tank this German tank about 2 000 of
them across Europe in a large number of
different countries and countries are
offering it but they need to get
Germany's permission to send it and then
there's calls for Germany to send some
of their stocks that they've got
um uh just just sitting around Germany
hasn't said no they've said they need
some more time to make a decision
um and some countries have already
started training Ukrainian Crews on the
tanks because it's very different to the
the tanks that the ukrainians are used
to operate creating you mentioned that
UK has decided to send 14 calendar 2
tanks very very capable tank that's a
complete Squadron and there'll be other
supporting armored vehicles on the
Challenger chassis with that
um and that will give them combined with
the US Bradley infantry Fighting Vehicle
which we see here and the as90 guns that
have been given ukrainians a capability
to have a real punch into the Russians
but they need more to be able to exploit
that and take it even further what's the
current state then on the ground well on
the ground I think I think part of
that's playing into the decision making
around with equipment bits and pieces
the ukrainians are having some success
in cremina in the Northeast there and
making some small advances but heavy
fighting going on there's also been some
buildup done as operation down in the
south on both sides and we're watching
to see what happens there but as it has
been for weeks in fact for over six
months now everything is running back
mode the Russians have been trying to
capture back mode for a good six months
uh last week they finished capturing the
little village the north of solidar with
the salt mines in it and there's been
some reports that have captured some of
the outlying areas of backwood to the
South as they try and encircle the city
and then use that as a stepping stone to
get through the rest of the Donetsk
region but the ukrainians are fixing
them in place they're holding them there
and they're causing the Russians to
stall that allows ukrainians potentially
to take some of their better troops send
them off into the West to get trained on
all of this equipment that's been
donated well staying in back moot then
one of the main military prisons they're
around at the moment is the Russian
mercenary group this is the Wagner group
there has been some tensions there just
enlighteners and what's going on there
real tensions and most of the fighting
as you said in bhakmud has been through
this Wagner group headed by prajogen
prajogan is a personal friend of
Vladimir Putin so he's got a direct line
into Moscow and into Putin which
bypasses the military chain of command
but he's also very critical not just of
some of the political decisions made by
defense minister in Northern but of the
commander on the ground so garasimov
who's just been appointed as the
commander on the ground for the whole of
Ukraine and prajogan sees him operating
outside his area of influence he was put
in to try and bring the Wagner group
um together Wagner have sourced some of
their equipment from North Korea and the
Americans have just released that and
that is looking at additional sanctions
and Wagner themselves has just been
declared an international criminal
organization and but if you've got two
military groups not operating operating
to a single chain of command that causes
real problems in any warfighting
situation Philip thank you very much
indeed for that update Philip Ingram
there